down by as many as 23 they cut at the
six before that mills three-pointer
james trying to get the three back and
he does lebron james from downtown
eight on the shot clock
johnson guarding him james to anthony
shot clock at three anthony on the drive
pull-up shot blocked from behind by
claxton deflected out of bounds
good job by class
brooklyn's gone cold james soars and
lays it
[Applause]
he's just playing so hard
the old one-man fast break i mean
mills has it
mills tied up cross court bruce brown
drives layup is good bruce brown with 16
big points
[Applause]
james drives on mills
feed to anthony for the slam
[Music]
westbrook kicks it out
and stanley johnson given all the room
but he's not going to take that
james goes it clacks and gets inside
banks at home two point game
excellent humility
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mills for three it's good patty mills
[Music]
james the three
now
lebron james from way downtown
by the mets but
again trying to get paddy mills on him
the switch the tire take the lead
[Applause]
james finds monk to the basket inside
lays it and we're tied brooklyn with the
ball
mills and harden
up to class and he throws it down and
the foul
what a pass and what a finish and a
chance for a three-point play
how spectacular was that play
you can't execute this if you tried it
10 more times the pass the delivery the
finish
over the contest that's good defense but
a spectacular job delivering it where
only claxton can catch and what a finish
nick claxton eight points six rebounds
four blocked shots and a big free throw
there
[Applause]
[Music]
james will bring it up a season high 39
for james here tonight
the hesitation the drive
has deflected out to westbrook westbrook
drives tried to jam it he missed it
rebound harden
they have to foul
and westbrook fouls harden that was a
foul to give
lebron james felt like which he was wide
open in that corner but you can't blame
westbrook
by the way that was not they're in the
penalty not a foul to give westbrook had
a good chance
and now harden will shoot free throws
westbrook is fourth foul
[Applause]
now a four-point lead arden 10 of 14
from the free-throw line
33 points 10 assists nine rebounds
remember he hadn't played
james harden in 15 days
[Applause]
two clutch free throws there
hardin and mills each with 34. 68 points
the starting backcourt for brooklyn
and the nets have a five-point lead with
20 seconds remaining
including james harden
magnificent mark
a lot of time off
could have made excuses
found a way to get it done spectacular
all-time great player
putting on a clinic on christmas
[Music]
he missed the three games with the
health and safety
issues and then the three games
postponed meanwhile patty mills has
played in every game this season
and playing his best basketball
has done it once again he is
been just spectacular for
steve nash
here tonight
lakers out of timeouts
either team with a foul to give brooklyn
still has a timeout remaining wayne
ellington comes in for his three-point
shooting
ellington looking
james go to by brown
precious time steps back three-pointer
shot no good rebound harden
and martin will walk it up lakers do
foul westbrook fowls with 10.7 remaining
[Applause]
martin can put this one away at the
free-throw line although
brooklyn weathered quite the storm here
in the fourth quarter
but this is quite a win
for brooklyn
to have
duran irving out
hardin just coming back off a 15-day
absence
the team hadn't played in a week i mean
it's really and going on a road against
a team
who had lost four straight and has
lebron james
it's a heck of a win
our nands to adds to his total
a triple-double a 36-point triple-double
the lead back up to seven they blew a
23-point lead
but then made the big plays in the final
seconds and that'll do it
brooklyn nets
the best road record in the nba now 12-3
on the road
lebron james disappointed despite some
spectacular plays here in the fourth
as the lakers lose their fifth in a row
including
three straight here at home and are now
two games under 500.
martin with 36
10 and 10.
patty mills with 34 but others played
well bruce brown a season high 16 points
nick claxton with some big plays
and after
brooklyn blew that 23-point lead they go
on a 7-0 run in the final 45 seconds